[Music]
and profession fraud news fraud fire
fest submit but I love dogs
really yeah yeah it's not even the same
thing that's like comparing a lobster to
like a like a alien alien okay yeah I
mean a human being and a dog two
different things true no but I feel like
before like before you have a kid Isis
Hollis that was your kid yeah you have
their dog like your kid but once you
have a kid then the dog kind of your
animal get away no I had a kid yeah I've
never had a dog you have a kid I know
you did the whole elbow thing Tim it
wasn't that bad all right god damn it no
but yes maybe because I've never owned a
dog I still like love dogs like crazy
where I I want to play oh and you love
dogs like crazy because you only see the
good stuff yeah I don't do already get
the hell pretty not pretty good but I
think it's cuz you hide your kid
category filth so you have the like dog
category but I didn't my dog was in this
case she can't get a dog dick too though
so I'm like but he says no let's wait
until you know our pets are go that's my
next dog I just wanna see KC sitting on
a couch petting a poodle if you get a
baby they'll get along with all of them
I know it's what I said I was just like
we should just get in three pets a woman
posing as a Walgreens pharmacist for
over a1 posed as a Walgreens pharmacist
for over 10 years what the [ __ ] would
ever posed as a wallet what are the
purse like this we should get good
benefit well no they do good I think
they get like 80 a year starting or some
[ __ ] she was getting a paycheck oh for
sure she was a farmer but she posed as a
pharmacist for 10 years oh I thought she
was just walking around saying she was a
pharmacist oh yeah I was like why would
you do how do the pharmacist for the
work she authorized more than 7
145,000 prescriptions without a license
that's what I mean I assumed that she
was getting the farm salary yeah every
she was also distributing drugs
illegally on the side and she was also
giving flu shots like everything
complaints why was it so no cuz they're
getting vicodin you're vicious goes this
is goes to show you [ __ ] school yeah for
sure cuz of what the [ __ ] is she yeah
she [ __ ] did it
kids you don't need no school right area
this happened in the Bay Area she's
making over six figures yeah yeah she
has worked in three stores three menthe
milk pitas and San Jose I know all those
three cities is it Fremont of nice city
to any thought she all worth it they're
all nice City they're all oh no Peters
just sounds really bad it just sounds
like friends and our San Jose is not a
nice city it's just tech boom area is
super old dingy
what about Milpitas no peter is like a
bunch of [ __ ] Filipino people dude
that's my family bro now what was the
other yeah you're the thousand months
south of Oakland and in Milpitas is
closer to Mountain View I think I didn't
mean [ __ ] feeling a bad way by the
way I just said it because it sounded
nice [ __ ] Filipinos yeah alliteration
I like that someone in the Filipino
group broke your heart yeah funky
Filipino [ __ ] [ __ ] alright so it's G
was a manager from 2006 through 2017 she
did go to school would be a pharmacy
tech oh so she's learned nothing
Braemore but she never finished her
education so she wasn't even licensed
for a pharmacy tech they look school
kids just half way yeah and then so she
was so when she applied at Walgreens to
get this job as a pharmacist she gave
them license numbers of two other actual
pharmacists that had a similar name as
her oh she's great fraud I bet you she's
Vietnamese because it's easy to have the
same name yup halibut amis pharmacist
did Janey win her name Kim Finley
you call me mammy so sexy they're saying
that more than a hundred thousand
prescriptions or for controlled
substances which had improper
documentation and no refill limit that's
pretty sick yeah couldn't they tell when
she had blonde hair and a roots are
coming out and a dragon tattoo on her
back that she's the wrong type of person
to be their pharmacist she was a coffee
shop girl gonna be a farm tech they're
like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
World War she was so smart that like she
was like this is easy I got all ready
yeah dude it's like - catch me if you
can guy yeah yeah yeah he faked being a
pilot for years that's [ __ ] crazy
it's really good
these people should be hired to help
find other frauds I agree
and then the real question is how many
times does she [ __ ] up and how many cuz
like if you do [ __ ] up you get written
up and then you get complaints and all
this stuff but she kept working him how
was she covered because of one of her
prescriptions it wasn't like she [ __ ]
up on one of the prescriptions and so
they realized that her knee was attached
to that and they looked into her 1 out
of 10 years that's a really good traffic
that is really that's the one that
they're reporting that she was a manager
you said yeah that's like a hundred
thirty hundred fifty thousand dollar
yeah that's a sick gig I'd be so scared
waking up every morning that today I'm
[ __ ] want to cut my [ __ ] losses
dude yeah oh yeah I would actually see
what like years I've been like you know
what I gotta come up but do you get
cocky man you got that kind of revenue
stream yeah a little cocky about it that
whole drug dealers thing right like I'm
just gonna do it til I get two million
but she one last job just one last day
at the pharmacy and I'm getting out
you'll see I'm going to Fiji that's like
De Niro and he dude he just need to do
one last job and he's going to Fiji bro
I always see that it's always one last
job and they get caught yeah yeah you
did their last job they called it out
but didn't he was dope is that he does
the last job succeeds and then he still
turns around because he wants to get
revenge against to do oh pretty soon
great movie check it out it's on that
foot enough
he Pacino and Gino engineer it's a nine
beams movie it's like 94 five or secret
of every I've never seen it's excellent
i watch this film dude it's not even
like it's a Korean film and [ __ ] Gina
sent me that [ __ ] and she was like
watches it'll make you cry and I'm like
yeah I'm pretty sure I'll tear up I
watch that [ __ ] bro
you know who cried in that film so I
have a roommate named Ray I've noticed I
was 2 years old I've never seen him cry
once and this fool was bawling I never
seen emotion that moment of that movie I
cried so [ __ ] much I actually soaked
the side of my shirt so two of you guys
were just watching it together with
Bucky what movie is this it's it's
called like along with the gods and it's
about it's about a guy who's you go
through like seven stages of Hell and
you have to prove your innocence
throughout that same seven stages a hell
in order to be high every already
exactly so when I saw that film right
yeah the first thing was have you said
or done anything that caused somebody to
kill themselves I was like okay I'm done
then because I'm pretty sure that cause
somebody actually killed himself
yeah and so that's like one all those
intense parts and I'm like looking at
that the moment I step in there they go
okay well let's go through 600 YouTube
videos I've literally said go kill
yourself like 400 days I think here's
why it's not my fault so that's a big
and so this guy has to go through these
seven stages that he'll and you get to
see his whole life unfold and I teared
up in the beginning but towards the end
I was done dude and I heard this sniffle
in the saasy he's right oh hey what did
your Mariel command take something I
didn't say it because I was trying to
hide myself that he could see me crying
so I was on the side of the couch
how do you hide it how do you hide it
I'll show you what I do when I hide it
what are you doing well this is how it
was there's a couch here and there's a
bean bag on the floor yeah I just hid
behind the couch and I started crying
and I look over at Raylan
[Laughter]
so for me if there's people on my side I
could already feel like coming on so
then like you know when it gets that
your tear line or whatever the water
starts rising I do this and I go you try
to blow the tears back in your eye I
start moving my eyes to let the water
but that's even more apparent than just
crying yeah they're like gee are you
jogging I'm doing it for camera I listen
is I feel one I've got to pull it down
then I just go I dab it like a G you
know like not me dude I let that
[ __ ] below you see a man okay
good I look alright and you just tears
coming I shake the tears off I shake it
off I go see men cry can make me laugh
harder than almost anything other than a
monkey holding a cigarette you know I
I'm sure yeah monkey monkeys monkeys
standing upright holding cigarettes that
part but dudes I like the whole life
looking it holding it for Clinton s yeah
I love that [ __ ] remember the best cry
yeah
[Applause]
I hate when I try to hold it in when I'm
trying to hold in my my tears but then
this shake [ __ ] goes crazy it starts
going down quivering like you can't hold
it in anymore and it just comes out
you've got to let it cry dude because
the more you hold it back that's stupid
the more stupid you look that's what's
funny about it though don't holding it
back she's so good especially on a dude
I just let a fluoride I'm actually the
opposite if I feel like I'm about to cry
I try to force the cry like I'm pooping
like I'm like you know you talk bleep
extra hot there's more tears that come
up because I want to cry I like crying
it's just not cinematic go Bart well
it's not how do I film that you know
weird movie theater we're doing a crime
you what I hold it in I'm like it's a
good damn thing damn big man like it's
just you know you're just kind of hot
then out of nowhere a [ __ ] cowboy hat
comes on exactly newsworthy I know I'm
forgiven dude yeah with the [ __ ]
straw heads this is not yeah just like
this bro date for me no more I love that
[ __ ]
[Music]